um I don't suppose any of you've ever
noticed that traditionally the best
picture award is presented solo probably
because they want some guy like me
messing around making comments about
sequins chiffon rude ringlets however
tonight it is my great pleasure to
introduce live from the White House the
First Lady of the United States Michelle
Obama
Thank You Jack and welcome to the White
House everyone I am so honored to help
introduce this year's nominees for best
picture and to help celebrate the movies
that lift our spirits broaden our minds
and transport us to places we have never
imagined this has been an exciting year
for movies and I want to congratulate
all the nominees on their tremendous
work these nine movies took us back in
time and all around the world
they made us laugh they made us weep and
they made us grip our armrest just a
little tighter they taught us that love
can endure against all odds and
transform our lives in the most
surprising ways and they reminded us
that we can overcome any obstacle if we
dig deep enough and fight hard enough
and find the courage to believe in
ourselves these lessons apply to all of
us no matter who we are or what we look
like or where we come from or who we
love but they are especially important
for our young people every day through
engagement in the arts our children
learn to open their imaginations to
dream just a little bigger and to strive
every day to reach those dreams and I
want to thank all of you here tonight
for being part of that vitally important
work and now I'm going to turn it back
over to you jack to give us the nominees
don't nobody mess around with that are
they
well let's recap the outstanding nine
nominees for tonight's Best Picture
amour
Argo
beasts of the southern wild
Django Unchained they miserable life of
pies
Lincoln
silver linings playbook
zero dark thirty mama do you have your
envelope not yet Jack but I'm about to
good and now for the moment we have all
been waiting for and the Oscar goes to
Argo
Argo has seven Academy
I know what you're thinking
three sexiest producers alive
I want to thank the Academy this is this
is this is truly an honor there there
are literally thousands of people to
thank so I thank Lee I'm not going to
thank them now I'm going to thank
everybody personally in the next few
weeks but there are a couple people I
want to acknowledge I want to
acknowledge my partner in crime and my
great friend George Clooney who
everybody should be so lucky to have a
partner who is talented and as humorous
and and who has as much integrity so
thank you George
I want to thank my beautiful wife Lisa
who yet you make it you make everything
better and to our kids Maya and Olivia I
love you guys hope your old man's not
embarrassing you up here um the reason I
wanted to speak first before I want to
speak before Ben was um been as a
producer on the film and he is also our
director and I thought it would be
awkward for Ben to thank himself but
it's not awkward for me so on behalf of
George and myself I want to thank you
Ben you directed a hell of a film
couldn't be more proud of the film
couldn't be more proud of been so ladies
and gentlemen our co-producer and the
director of Argo Ben Affleck very much
thank you very very much I know
eventually that thing's going to start
to go so forgive me if this is a little
bit quick I want to knowledge Steven
Spielberg who I feel is a genius and a
towering talent among us I want to
acknowledge the other eight films there
are eight great films that have every
right as much a right to be up here as
we do I want to acknowledge them and
thank them for what they did and for
many of them who didn't even get
nominated this year I want to thank you
know I mean Jack McNeese and George
Becka and Marty breasted my brother and
my mom and dad and Patrick Weitzel and
Tony Mendez who let us do his story
thank you and I just I'm gonna forget I
thank everyone in the movie on the movie
worked on the movie did anything with
this movie gets thanked I want to thank
Canada I want to thank our friends in in
Iran living in a terrible circumstances
right now I want to thank my wife who I
don't normally associate with Iran but I
want to thank you for working on our
marriage for at 10 Christmases it's it's
good it is work but it's the best kind
of work and there's no one I'd rather
work with and I just want to say you
know I was here 15 years ago or
something and you know I had no idea
what I was doing I stood out here in
front of you all I really just a kid and
I went out you know and I never thought
that I would be back here and I am
because of so many of you who are here
tonight because of this Academy because
of so many wonderful people who extended
themselves to me when they had nothing
to benefit from it in Hollywood you know
I mean I couldn't get him a job I want
to thank them and I want to thank what
they taught me which is that you have to
work harder than you then you think you
possibly can
can't hold grudges it's hard you can't
hold grudges and it doesn't matter how
you get knocked down in life because
that's going to happen all the managers
that you got to get up
violet Sam and Sarah I love you